let's actually zoom out because I don't
think we talked about the data engine
the entirety of the layout of this idea
that I think is just beautiful with
humans in the loop can you describe the
data engine
yeah the data engine is what I call the
almost biological feeling like process
by which you uh perfect the training
sets for these neural networks
um so because most of the programming
now is in the level of these data sets
and make sure they're large diverse and
clean oh basically you have a data set
that you think is good you train your
neural net you deploy it and then you
observe how well it's performing and
you're trying to uh always increase the
quality of your data set so you're
trying to catch scenarios basically
there are basically rare and uh it is in
these scenarios that the neural Nets
will typically struggle in because they
weren't told what to do in those rare
cases in the data set but now you can
close the loop because if you can now
collect all those at scale you can then
feed them back into the Reconstruction
process I described and uh reconstruct
the truth in those cases and add it to
the data set and so the whole thing ends
up being like a staircase of improvement
of perfecting your training set and you
have to go through deployments so that
you can mine uh the parts that are not
yet represented well in the data set
so your data set is basically imperfect
it needs to be diverse it has pockets
there are missing and you need to pad
out the pockets you can sort of think of
it that way
in the data what role do humans play in
this so what's the uh this biological
system like a human body is made up of
cells what what role like how do you
optimize the human uh system the the
multiple Engineers collaborating
figuring out what to focus on or to
contribute which which task to optimize
in this neural network
uh who is in charge of figuring out
which task needs more data what can you
can you speak to the hyper parameters
the human uh system it really just comes
down to extremely good execution from an
engineering team and does what they're
doing they understand intuitively the
philosophical insights underlying the
data engine and the process by which the
system improves and uh how to again like
delegate the strategy of the data
collection and how that works and then
just making sure it's all extremely well
executed and that's where most of the
work is is not even the philosophizing
or the research or the ideas of it it's
just extremely good execution it's so
hard when you're dealing with data at
that scale so your role in the data
engine executing well on it it is
difficult and extremely important is
there a priority of like uh like a
vision board of saying like
we really need to get better at
stoplights
like the the prioritization of tasks is
that essentially and that comes from the
data that comes to um a very large
extent to what we are trying to achieve
in the product for a map where we're
trying to the release we're trying to
get out
um in the feedback from the QA team
where the system is struggling or not
the things we're trying to improve and
the QA team gives some signal some
information
in aggregate about the performance of
the system in various conditions and
then of course all of us drive it and we
can also see it it's really nice to work
with the system that you can also
experience yourself you know it drives
you home it's is there some insight you
can draw from your individual experience
that you just can't quite get from an
aggregate statistical analysis of data
yeah it's so weird right yes it's it's
not scientific in a sense because you're
just one anecdotal sample yeah I think
there's a ton of uh it's a source of
truth it's your interaction with the
system yeah and you can see it you can
play with it you can perturb it you can
get a sense of it you have an intuition
for it I think numbers just like have a
way of numbers and plots and graphs are
you know much harder yeah it hides a lot
of it's like if you train a language
model
it's a really powerful way is by you
interacting with it yeah 100 try to
build up an intuition yeah I think like
Elon also like he always wanted to drive
the system himself he drives a lot and
uh I'm gonna say almost daily so uh he
also sees this as a source of Truth you
driving the system
um and it performing